so here we go marvin bagley is starting
tonight for sacramento
and they're also getting another player
hassan whiteside with a shot outside
that will drop in right there
and curry knocks it in inbound comes
from the former number one overall pick
out of kansas that's andrew wiggins
he was traded to this team middle of
last season curry again this is a three
puts it down steph curry and kevin his
length and his skill and obviously
ability to post up
early on taking advantage bagley with so
much potential but that guy right there
stephen kerr on the other end stephen
curry so good as we talked about moving
without the basketball
tourer's achilles practicing before
camps opened in los
angeles and out for a second consecutive
year for the golden state warriors
your heart goes out to klay thompson
just a great talent great young man and
stephen curry
is on fire for the golden state warriors
four of five with three threes and we'll
step aside
on tnt holmes gets two right there
here comes crow behind the back he takes
it into a thicket and gets it to go
what a play by steph curry wow what ball
handling
hey with four and a half to go in the
second watch
yeah he looks like he's in rhythm lost
it a little bit but luck favors the
prepared man
behind the back maybe he did that on
purpose who knows
well with him he's a magician and you
can see the way
he takes it in fearlessly with the
deflection
wiggins the other way wiggins and uber
were singled out by kerr
ubrey has screamed curry the three down
the hatchet go of course getting out in
transition his teammates know
find stephen curry more than cape kevin
it's paid off indeed
you have to admire his perseverance uh
his journey and here he is now
with golden state and really being
productive here in his nba career
hesitating curry puts it up and in what
a play
for his own health as he goes up for two
and fouled on the play
barnes will pick it up yeah and that
right there
stephen curry we know he can shoot the
ball from the perimeter
he's got the ball right now and he draws
the defensive heel and down low to curry
with a fake and a drive and a feed shot
clock at seven
dear steph with a spinner and down the
hatch it goes
and right now golden state
steph curry trying to take over and does
just that how about that kevin i've been
impressed with rashawn holmes but look
at this here on roshawn homes
curry just taking his time behind the
back able to get to the rim and finish
with these
good lead he caught it in strident
jordan pool hammers at home
clint robinson from outside rebound by
chris
here comes poole 10-point game curry
free
kaboom puts it inside been hurt
hadn't played a lot this is his first
time playing so i bet you he is spent
out there right now deservedly so
curry dancing driving shooting in town
it goes
pretty play by steph curry